Hyena females may be the most powerful ladies
in the animal kingdom.
Hyena societies are entirely matriarchal,
which means that adult females are the ones
in charge.
The dominant females are highest on the social
scale, followed by their own cubs, then lower
ranking females and their cubs, and finally,
adult males.
And it’s impossible for these male to have
sex with a female if she’s not on board
with the action, due to the female’s unique
‘masculinized’ genitalia.
It’s impossible to tell the difference between
young hyena males and females just by looking
at them.
It looks so similar that it’s actually termed
a pseudopenis.
In addition, the females’ labia are fused
together, and they also hang from the body,
which looks like a scrotum.
In fact, this is called - you guessed it-
a pseudoscrotum.
In order for a male to have sex with a female,
she must first invert her pseudopenis into
her own body - much like turning a sock inside
out.
Once her pseudopenis is tucked into her own
body, the male can then insert his penis.
If she doesn’t tuck in her pseudopenis,
he’s completely out of luck.
But before we get too carried away in singing
the praises of female hyenas, we must also
remember that they have to give birth through
their unique penile structures.
Both first-time moms and their cubs have an
unusually high death rate during birth.
Cubs can become asphyxiated very easily during
their journey down a 30 centimeter tube that
is a mere four to five centimeters in width!
As the first cub is born, it usually rips
open the females’ pseudopenis such that
future births are less traumatic (but still
highly so).
While it must feel good to be a powerful female
hyena, it isn’t always a walk in the park.
The most natural question to pose in this
situation is WHY?
Baby hyenas have strong jaws and sharp teeth.
Siblicide is common especially on female cubs.
Females stand to climb higher on the social
ladder without sisters around.
And males, well, males would do better if
they had no sisters at all.
So they’ve evolved to be physically identical
to each other so that they do not specifically
target the females in acts of siblicide.
Isn’t family great?
Want to see more animal videos?
Check this one out by our friends at The Dodo.
Don't forget to subscribe and keep coming
back to Seeker for more videos!